this is kizzy  a black and white ruffed lemur  she calls the rainforests of eastern  madagascar home  and unfortunately home is disappearing  black and white roughed lemurs grow up  to four feet and close to ten pounds  making them one of the larger lima  species  besides making for a curious look  their extra thick fur helps protect them  from rainfall as water just runs off it  they are an all-female dominant social  group and live mostly high in the trees  where they search for fruit to eat  while they don't have many natural  predators  accelerated habitat loss from logging  has left them critically endangered  this is the black and white ruffed lemur  you